[Musique]
alexandra bonetti et joueuses
professionnelles sur le circuit européen
mais avant d'en faire son métier le golf
est avant tout une passion pour cette
parisienne de 25 ans la sportive à taper
ses premières balles à l'âge de 7 ans au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines après avoir vu ses parents
joués décidé à s'améliorer elle a
ensuite pris des cours dans la structure
sur l'impulsion de sa famille
on a dû commencer à prendre des leçons
vers l'âge de 10 ans il avait une super
école de apprécie vraiment vraiment
super donc je suis resté jusqu'à mes 17
ans tous les week-ends cette passion à
développer son esprit de compétition
2007 à saint quentin divina golfeuses
décroche à 15 ans la médaille de bronze
du championnat d'europe dames en étant
invité du tournoi un moment clé dans sa
jeune carrière
impensable suite à cette performance
alexandra bonetti intègre l'équipe de
france termine troisième du championnat
du monde amateur en argentine en 2010 et
rafle l'or au championnat d'europe dames
en 2014
après son bac elle joue dans une
université au texas entre 2011 et 2015
et sillonne les greens américain pour
continuer à engranger les succès sur le
circuit la joueuse s'entraîne de façon
intense six jours sur sept
donc il ya cinq séances de sport par
semaine que je fais soit le matin avant
de venir au golf soit dans la soirée et
ensuite c'est un
un équilibre entre le practice le petit
jeu donc petit shipping et le parcours
donc ça prend pas mal de temps
un entraînement nécessaires pour
réaliser une quinzaine de tournois par
an quatre coins du monde et surtout pour
perfectionner son point fort le jeu
court pour cela alexandra a mis en place
une technique
je vais prendre beaucoup de recul
derrière la bad pour regarder une
première fois la ligne sur tous les
mouvements gauche droite puis je vais
aller de l'autre côté là je vais aller
un peu moins loin pour surtout me
centrer sur la fin du pote et les
mouvements à près du trou et ensuite je
vais repasser par le côté le plus bas
cette technique sur le jeu court lui
permettra peut-être de réussir à
intégrer le circuit américain dame à
l'horizon 2019
l'un de ses plus grands rêves de golf us
à bientôt